what's the story with a bitcoin etf
[Music]
bitcoin has arrived on main street with
the launch of a u.s exchange traded fund
that matters because it opens up what
was once a very niche investment to a
much wider pool of potential buyers
you no longer need an account with a
special cryptocurrency exchange or a
futures trading venue
now anyone with a brokerage account can
get price exposure
there's been a lot of excitement in the
weeks immediately following the launch
the market cap of the fund shot to 1.3
billion dollars
what's more this is unlikely to be the
last etf tracking the price of bitcoin
but you really need to read the fine
print
when you put money in a gold etf
custodians go out and buy actual
physical bars and put them in a vault
that creates demand for gold and the
price rises
that's not the case with the current
crop of u.s bitcoin products
instead the sec has decided to approve
only products backed by cash settled
futures contracts
for now at least
in other words the assets that link the
price of the fund to that of bitcoin are
futures contracts which themselves
aren't settled in actual bitcoin but
rather in cash
that has two rather big implications for
the bullish investors
number one demand is transferred away
from actual bitcoin to futures contracts
and unlike bitcoin the supply of futures
contracts is potentially infinite
and number two
rolling the futures contract forward
from one month to the next means that it
is likely to substantially underperform
bitcoin when crypto is rallying which
means that the lineup of crypto etfs
likely to emerge in the us will be more
like trading vehicles and less suitable
for the buy and hold bitcoin bull or the
hodlers as they called
this is decrypted i'm eddie van der walt
lurking in the shadows as producer
matthew long for more content like this
follow us on your favorite platforms